Cookie Clicker is a game about clicking a
cookie.
It’s simple at first, but gets increasingly
complex.
The late game meta has elaborate strategies
to maximise cookie production, to unlock all
the upgrades and achievements, and to uncover
the deep lore of the grandmapocalypse, the
krumblor dragon, and the mysteries of the
cookie universe.
In the beginning, you click the cookie – which
gets you one cookie.
You click again, you’ve got two.
Then three.
With fifteen cookies, you can buy a cursor
that clicks for you, making cookies automatically.
Ten cursors make one cookie per second, or
one CpS.
So you make more cookies, to buy more cursors,
to make more cookies – then for a hundred
cookies, you buy your first grandma.
This kindly old woman performs unpaid labour
to grow your cookie business – your cookies
become popular in the neighbourhood , then
renowned all over town . Production accelerates
exponentially.
You buy cookie farms to grow cookies, mines
to extract cookies from the earth, factories
to produce cookies on an industrial scale.
The cookie economy transforms the world around
it – chocolate pollutes the rivers , there’s
an obesity epidemic . But the world is too
hooked on cookies to stop – economists say
that “"cookies permeate the economy", and
"If we start eating anything else, we're all
dead" ”. Cookie banks start using cookies
as currency . At temples, thousands pray to
the Baker in the sky . There is no value,
no ideology, and no meaning beyond cookies.
You produce hundreds of thousands of cookies
a second, straining the fabric of reality
itself . You build wizard towers and alchemy
labs to summon cookies magically, you fly
in shipments from space of cookies from alien
worlds.
You open portals to a parallel dimension,
taking in millions of cookies per second.
Alien beings and cosmic elder gods come to
taste your cookies , and whole cities are
engulfed in transdimensional disaster , but
the system can’t stop, it can only grow,
cookies are all we know.
A local “confused idiot” says “you gotta
admit, all this cookie stuff is a bit ominous”
. Time machines bring cookies from the past,
corrupting history with abominations of dough
. You make cookies from antimatter, from light,
from pure chance, you make cookies from other
cookies, and cookies from beyond the fourth
wall, you make trillions of cookies a second.
The foundations of the cosmos crack under
the mass of the cookie economy.
Everything is transformed, either into cookies
or into the means to create cookies – “The
universe [becomes] cookie dough, [down] to
the molecular level” , an infinite “sentient”
terrifying cookie gestalt . The only escape
from the cosmic cookie machine is death – – yet
not even that can save you.
When you’re ready, you ascend – you leave
the mortal world for a higher plane of cookie
existence, where you can buy special Heavenly
Upgrades.
Then you are reborn in a new game, with zero
cookies, to start it all again.
But you keep certain upgrades and bonuses,
so you can quickly reach and surpass where
you were before.
Birth, death and rebirth are an endless inescapable
cycle of cookie samsara.
And the mechanics get more complex.
Cookie Clicker is an idle game.
You’re not meant to sit there clicking the
cookie – you’re meant to leave it on in
the background while it makes cookies for
you, and occasionally come back to spend cookies
on upgrades.
In the early game, this passive playstyle
is efficient.
Upgrades like the Golden Lock and the Shimmering
Veil optimise for idle cps.
But in the late game, the best way to progress
is with an active playstyle.
Cause every five minutes or so, a Golden Cookie
spawns – if you click it in time, you get
a random temporary bonus like a Cookie Frenzy,
which increases your cookie production by
seven times for one minute.
The best effect is the Building Special, which
temporarily multiplies your rate of production
based on how many buildings you have – so
if you have hundreds of buildings, that can
multiply your cps by thousands of times over.
And if you can stack multiple multipliers
together, you can increase production by millions
of times over.
You can spawn more Golden Cookies with the
Grimoire – the minigame unlocked at the
Wizard Tower.
One of the Grimoire spells, called Force The
Hand of Fate summons a Golden Cookie.
So by manipulating the Mana pool by strategically
selling Towers, and by spending Sugar Lumps
to replenish Mana, you can cast the Hand of
Fate spell several times in a row, reliably
generating three or four golden cookies at
once.
If you’re lucky, and those cookies grant
multiple Building Specials, you can generate
CpS multipliers of millions of times regular
production, making weeks worth of cookies
in minutes.
To make the most of these bonuses, you need
certain plants from the Cookie Garden.
The Garden grows cookie seeds into cookie
plants, which can mutate along a complex cookie
evolutionary trees to unlock new seeds with
new effects – like thumbcorn buffs clicking,
and cheapcap reduces prices, but the good
shit is bakeberries.
When harvested bakeberries, give you 30 minutes
worth of cookie production instantly.
So, if you harvest them while you’ve got
a huge CpS multiplier from Golden Cookies,
you can make months worth of cookies instantly.
You can fill the garden with bakeberries,
freeze them at maturity, and keep spawning
Golden Cookies til you get a huge multiplier,
then harvest all the bakeberries at once,
for massive profit.
Alternatively, you can go for the Click Frenzy
Golden Cookie effect, which synergises with
the Godzamok Pantheon idol.
Once you’ve got Krumblor the Cookie Dragon,
you can do some pretty wild shit with the
Dragon’s Fortune and Dragonflight Auras,
though for passive play the Breath of Milk
aura is usually ideal for the buff to kittens.
Of course, the seasonal events like Christmas
are also essential, so you can upgrade Santa
from an elf fetus to a Bulky elf to Elder
Santa and then to Final Claus, who grants
dominion of his realm, and a cheeky 20% cps
bonus.
So the late game involves a variety of strategies
to min-max for optimal cookie production.
But the cookies are not without cost.
As production increases, the grandmas grow
discontent.
“You make me sick” grandma says.
“You could have stopped it”, grandma says.
After the Bingo Center upgrade, and the One
Mind tech tree, the Grandmapocalypse begins.
[Nanageddon music].
The indentured labour force at the bottom
of the pyramid rebels, a hive mind of mutant
grandmas rise , and transform the globe into
an eldritch horror-scape of cookie-based monstrosity.
Wrinkled "flesh tendrils" are visible from
space , writhing masses of dough engulf whole
cities , spreading like an infectious virus.
The only way to end the Grandmapocalypse is
with an Elder Covenant – you can sacrifice
some economic gain to save everyone.
But it can actually be more efficient to continue
the disaster, and send everyone back to work
anyway.
Because the Grandmapocalypse spawns Wrinklers.
Wrinklers leech 5% of CpS, but when you pop
them, they give back more than they took.
So you can increase economic production by
risking the lives of the elderly.
Disaster is actually an opportunity to exploit
the vulnerable to make more wealth.
Ultimately, the cookie economy is not designed
to help people, it just makes cookies – like
a virus or a tumour, its nature is to exploit
everything around it for its own expansion.
Grandmas, banks, temples, every part of life
is perverted to serve the purpose of ‘the
economy’.
Nothing is too sacred to be sacrificed on
its altar.
And for what?
What's the point of a massive global economy
if it fails to protect the elderly and the
vulnerable?
Even those with the most cookies don’t really
benefit from the system – past a certain
level of wealth, you can never spend that
many cookies.
And it’s not like the game ever ends.
You cannot win.
You just keep making cookies until you stop
or you die.
You’re just hoarding cookies for its own
sake.
It’s not really about the cookies – it’s
about accumulation, getting more.
You could be collecting any meaningless number
– points, subscribers, small green pieces
of paper – past a certain point, you’re
just making a number go up.
It’s not even a real number, cause look,
behind the scenes, you can cheat, you can
literally type in a number and print two trillion
cookies out of thin air [cookie printer goes
brrr], their value is imaginary.
And yet the lives and health of our grandmas
are being risked to increase this imaginary
number.
The problem is that a system designed to make
cookies is not designed to make wellbeing,
justice and happiness.
Any system of endless growth, of singular
purpose, that warps the whole world around
one goal – can only grow until it self-destructs.
The only way we can escape such a game…
is to stop playing.
Thanks for watching this video about Cookie
Clicker.
You can play the game at the link below.
The game is made by Orteil and Opti – consider
supporting them on Patreon.
Make sure to click the like and click subscribe
and click the bell so that our numbers go
up.
Thanks to Patrons Jader Fontoura de Moraes,
Jamie Starr, Lisa Penelton, and LeglessLegolas.
Cheers.